i've been covering how right wing media
has been covering the biden
administration for several months now
and the bottom line is that they do not
know what the hell to do with themselves
the joe biden administration so far has
been completely absent of scandals
they've made some progress in some areas
they've turned around some of the
disasters left behind by the donald
trump administration
for example vaccination has accelerated
dramatically
the economy continues to recover jobs
are recovering
stock market is at a record high joe
biden passed a coronavirus stimulus he's
now pushing infrastructure reform he's
doing guns
he's doing a lot of different things so
right-wing media has had to come up
with scandals but they're really boring
and they're sort of what i would call
fake
scandals one is the focus on
why joe biden and kamala harris won't go
to the border and of course
you know they have advisors uh they
don't need to
go to the border to understand what's
going on at the border but that's one
fake scandal that the right has been
pushing
they've done the cancel culture stuff
focusing
occasionally and intermittently on dr
seuss or major league baseball or
whatever the case may be
they try gotcha questions at press
briefings with joe biden's press
secretary jen saki or sometimes
with joe biden himself and the gotcha
questions
fail day after day after day in a
humiliating way
here is the latest fake scandal
i present to you now an entire news max
segment devoted to how kamala harris
laughs
and when she laughs i'm not kidding here
is a segment
very concerned about kamala's laugh and
drawing a parallel to the wicked witch
of the west i guess from the wizard of
oz take a look
so it got me thinking about kamala's
cackling alright she is probably going
to be president sooner than rather than
later all right
she's supposed to be the leader all
women should look up to
but all i can actually remember her
doing since taking office
is cackling at the most strange moments
too watch
kits
[Applause]
you know
[Laughter]
not everybody landed punches like you
did though
so you don't mean it
oh it's not even funny
so i was racking my brain watching those
clips right there
trying to figure out who in the heck
does this woman remind me of and then i
realized
she's from out west and it hit me
[Laughter]
oh boy that's her
that's cackling kamala the wicked witch
of the west
nancy pelosi move over there's a new
witch in town
and her name of course is cackling
kamala
oh how sad is that she is going to be
president by the way i don't think joe
biden's going to be in here for much
longer
we'll see right i don't wish any harm to
him at all but
we shall see guys kamala is laughing
the wrong way and at the wrong time this
is an explosive issue
now if you thought uh first of all
how many segments has newsmax done about
how male politicians laugh
you're asking an interesting question
and as far as i know the answer is zero
secondly is there some sense in which
this is refreshing because we know that
these aren't real scandals what i mean
by that is
trump failing on coronavirus and the
number of deaths that that caused
trump regularly making the u.s a global
laughing stock
trump launching a misguided trade war
trump crushing farmers with his policy
you know all of these real
issues now the scandal is how kamala
harris laughs and whether major league
baseball should be boycotted
is there some sense in which it's
refreshing that these aren't
real embarrassing scandals at a global
level
i don't know but in all seriousness they
have no
idea what to do with themselves and it's
getting
very embarrassing i would expect more of
this now
at some point there may be a real biden
administration scandal
many administrations have scandals like
for example when barack obama wore a tan
suit that rocked the world so
at some point there may be a real
scandal
and it could very quickly become a sort
of boy who cried wolf type of situation
but kamala laughing guys come on you're
embarrassing yourselves
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
deepakman we're going to take some of
your calls i'm going to answer
many of your questions we have a great
program for you today
stay with us back right after this one
of our sponsors is apostrophe
a prescription skin care company for
people ready to start taking their acne
seriously prescription acne treatment
really does work
and apostrophe makes it easy to see a
board-certified dermatologist
online you'll get treated immediately
medications are delivered
to your home no waiting at the doctor or
at the pharmacy
you answer some questions on the website
take a few pictures of your skin and
your dermatologist will prepare
a personalized treatment plan tailored
to your specific needs apostrophe treats
acne but they can also help with issues
like redness wrinkles
and dark spots i went through the
questionnaire process myself
everything is super easy they ship right
to your house
it's really a great experience
apostrophe will give you
fifteen dollars off your first
dermatologist visit
at apostrophe.com pacman the link is
underneath this video and make sure to
use the coupon code
pacman